Yeah,
it might be the greatest task facing,
say the next American president on the
foreign policy realm is to reestablish
the moral authority of the United States
as a human rights actor.
Now,
I don't want to overstate the case that
the US does still have an important
voice say to stop genocide.
Um,
the US has actually been an important
rhetorical voice under four because the
United States does not commit mass
murder.
It's not,
you know,
ethnically cleansing hundreds of
thousands of people.
So in that sense,
there is still some residual moral
authority to the United States.
The US can also credibly promote
democracy because,
you know,
whatever flaws we have in the United
States,
it still is a credible democracy,
but the US cannot,
with a straight face promote the fight
against torture,
fight against foreseeable disappearance,
the fight against arbitrary detention
and the fight against unfair trials
because these are all abuses that the
Bush administration is practiced in the
name of fighting terrorism.
So the real challenge facing a new
government is to end those practices,
to repudiate them,
to hold the author's accountable in some
meaningful way.
And to recommit the United States to
serious respect for human rights,
even in the tough moments,
even when the US is at threat.
And in doing that,
I think that the United States can
reclaim its position as one of the
leaders,
if not the leader of the human rights
movement at the governmental level.
That is absolutely essential.
I think in the longterm,
if the human rights movement is to have
the power that is enjoyed in an earlier
era.